[Music]
there's a real timeless quality about
Christie looks like a combination of
Rock Hudson and John Wayne in this movie
one of guys that handsome
you know people project movie star into
them more than actor inevitably people
wanted to start a big franchise movies I
was just shaking you know I'm I mean
Captain Kirk
Captain Kirk I was so excited and I was
like I got I got to be cool gotta be
cool gotta be professional as soon as I
saw him rehearsing and he was on set he
was in character it totally went away
when I was sitting with him I looked
over at him I saw my dad when you with
him you feel in the moment I went and
saw him on stage and he was a phenomenal
stage actor and he's a guy who really
wants a career of really meaningful work
I think this movie is a unique
opportunity for him as an actor I get to
play something a bit quieter than I've
ever gotten before and I really really
love that about Toby that the cowboy
aesthetic of this film is of a certain
species of film that I grew up watching
it was your classical form of
masculinity women don't have to say much
or struggle to find ways to be intimate
really appealed to me the great thing
about Toby is at Toby
although he is the leading man in all of
the ways is very buttoned down and very
uptight about the things that you need
to do and sort of upset with himself
about how he's got into the situation so
he's he's kind of very introverted and
so to take an actor who's normally in
playing ex-royal character to be
introverted is a really interesting
thing to be able to contain all that
kind of you know mixed and answered a
desperate emotion in a very very nuanced
way throughout the film is a real
achievement
[Music]
you